foreign
[Music]
came about uh via my friends and former
colleagues
actually invited me back to do for like
a little development gig to look through
the archives or old stories that might
make jumping off points for
documentaries and um I actually before
even looking I knew I wanted to look
into
uh the incredible David Reimer story uh
that Keith Barrison and Ruth janetz had
had done many years ago because it was
such a mind-blowing story in and of
itself but it also seemed like really
like there would be other relevance with
our new kind of evolving understanding
of gender
um I didn't understand yet about the uh
connection to the treatment of intersex
people in the years that followed but
looking not only in the story as it
aired but also in the field tapes there
was that incredible on Exchange that we
use in the film where uh David reimer's
making it clear that the reason that he
decided to come forward and show his
face and speak publicly was that he was
so horrified to see that the
misinterpretation of his case was being
used to justify surgery on intersex
people and it just seemed especially
since he had already passed away that it
was almost like a
grave of like you know there's more
going on here leading to look at the you
know kind of modern day intersex Rights
Movement which is just you know with
river and others just growing and
blossoming and doing so many cool and
fascinating things that it just seemed
like incredible material for a
documentary absolutely so when did you
reach out to river and river how did you
feel when you heard from Miss Julie Khan
um
first of all thank you so much for
having us
um
Julie first reached out to Alicia
um and Alicia reached out to saifa and
we were all friends through the online
intersex community and
um we hadn't hung out a few times
throughout the year since I came out
um and Alicia and Cipher were planning
the process that you saw Juan porno and
I they asked me um if I wanted to come
and participate and the first time I
came on to set was when I was doing the
posters with them and according to Julie
I would pop on the camera
the next day I participated in the
in the protest and
um I
certified a lot to say
um and Julie then asked me if I wanted
to participate in documentary and to be
a third subject and honestly I was
pretty hesitant at first it's just being
this vulnerable not in like the
container of being an actor in a story
in a movie or a play or whatever
um but very quickly I found out that
Julie is a filmmaker of most integrity
and just
kindness and love and she created an
environment with the crew on the set
that just it was just such a safe place
safe space for me to be authentically
myself and
um so much so that like I never thought
my mom would be like on camera like that
and you know to share that moment where
I could
I don't know more than just being
vulnerable just like really being like
real and being myself and I I just
credit them to Julie's amazing abilities
as a filmmaker
just speaking of um leaving aside my
amazingness for a moment and speaking of
uh the cool and amazing and supportive
crew I think uh our lady
Anova it might be out here this evening
[Applause]
wow yeah um Julie I'm really curious to
hear about
um your approach to uh going into this
process and talking to people about
their trauma on camera and I think that
you know the documentary world is trying
really hard to take accountability for
the fact that you know
um the history of documentary has this
um this his there is this history of you
know subjects of documentaries being
taken advantage of or just being kind of
used and then left in the dust
yeah I'd love to hear especially for
aspiring filmmakers like what have you
found to be the best way to approach
participants in a documentary and make
them feel comfortable and treat them so
well
you know I think I mean these are all
big questions that are swirling around
very much I I saw the documentary
subject as I'm wondering whether you did
as well I kind of actually in the midst
of making this film certainly
um
raise those questions I mean there's
there's a number of different things a
lot of
hard
what makes you sensitive in making a dog
is sort of basic human human
thoughtfulness and the listening Hood
um but I think in in this case uh fair
amount had to do with kind of the choice
of participants and making sure that it
was people who
were already talking publicly about
their bodies in fact I learned River
story not through an interview but
through that scene that you see in the
film where they're talking with a
bullhorn describing you know the pretty
traumatic surgery that happened to them
as a teenager and
um
it really
uh touched me listening to it and that's
kind of when it was like wow this person
really would be um incredible to be to
be in the film when it came to I was
quite worried about I mean you know we
did have a Consulting producer uh
knishnik who's an intersex person
um
was one of the writers of the notorious
RBG so um myself and my uh RBG directing
partner Betsy West and actually eat her
and then she comes out as intersex so it
was a really nice uh Confluence
um but
um
I had worried like how am I gonna ask
you know these intrusive prodding
questions
what had the first interview that I did
with each
participant the first major sit-down
interview which is the sort of face
quite large on camera all of which is
natural light by the way customer feels
like so ironic saying this right now but
like bright lights shining into one
space that can can feel a little bit
intimidating uh so we we did is that we
did these As Natural Light uh interviews
I could really plan those as like
getting to know each other interviews
like building trust and I'm not going to
ask about like too many questions here
we'll just see how the conversation goes
and then the first two that I did
because River did come into the story a
little later so that we didn't hadn't
planned out a sit-down interview but the
in the interviews with Alicia and scypha
they just started talking
um I wasn't sure we were talking about
surgery at all and I didn't know we were
talking about reproductive organs in
those conversations but just saying like
tell me about your childhood like there
it was
um
which was and almost everything they
were saying was really absorbing
yeah River um I'm used to hear like uh
if you have it from your perspective
taking part in this any advice for
filmmakers who are trying to work on a
documentary and want to be better
keepers of their participants or
subjects stories and what was really
helpful for you in that process
yeah it was helpful and inspiring for me
in the process of working with Julie on
this was that it felt really like a
collaboration that felt like I had just
as much say in like you know ideas about
what we were going to do and how not
really sure things but what we were
going to do when when
um it was always an active
conversation and the stream of
communication was always very fluid it
didn't feel like oh Julie's like this
director on this hierarchy it just felt
like we were all kind of team players on
I think for a lot of directors I mean
myself included uh we had this idea that
it's about control but really it's about
I mean so according but like teamwork
and and great movies I think are really
in that Synergy of wanting to all create
the best thing for Humanity and I think
that's something that Julie was able to
accomplish
or we all accomplished
yes
um Julie how did you find in the
research process when you started
speaking to people
for expert opinion
et cetera how did you find
was there resistance for people excited
like what was that process like
um you know within both the intersex
community and those sort of the small
pool of people who've been fighting for
intersex rights for a long time I would
say there was like a
palpable
anticipation for like oh yes we've been
before we want we want this you know
story to be out in the world
um I did have the thought going in that
we really needed some a medical expert
to give some explanatory stuff I knew I
wanted that person to be intersex
because I was trying to get away from
the Divide of my oh there's the people
in the lived experience or whatever but
then
then therefore to really know what's
going on and though I actually did think
it was important to have someone who was
an MD you know and had that
you know the credentials to to say some
things I knew I wanted on that person to
be intersex of that sound
um I I reached out to drunk
I'm also um curious I really love the
choice to
um during the the portion where we're
learning about David reimer's story
um the choice to show that footage to
saifa and Alicia and river and then film
that as well that seemed like
just
interesting choice I'd love to hear more
about that
well that sounds like like a lot of
things in Doc world I don't know if this
is true in narrative film too like the
things that make things work on they're
just like there's like a problem that
you're trying to figure out how to solve
and the problem was like well we have
these two very different stories we've
got these modern day
live active people telling their life
stories and out there in a verite way
fighting for stuff and then we have this
like crazy Stranger Than Fiction 50 year
old archival voice Story how is it gonna
how are you gonna feel like you're
watching one movie
so
you know the thought was like we should
be making that connection by showing
pieces of this footage actually but
there's there's more of the footage in
the film than what was actually shown
and although as we once we edited that
sequence together we actually went back
around and showed some additional
footage to to River just
are just some more of those
um connect it was really just a way of
connecting
these two very disparate parts of the
film
yeah I thought it to me it made me feel
like we were learning about it together
like the audience kind of had that
feeling of seeing themselves on screen
uh and doing it all as one it also
allowed
you know there's some stuff that just
needed some explanation
people like a lot of dog people I'm
trying to stay away from narration at
this point but it allowed rather than
letting me narrated the film I said a
couple things except that they were in
the form of the questions and
conversations with the participants in
the film
um so it was kind of like she didn't put
some narration in there
um remember I love you love your mom
um
I thought that the
back to New Jersey
so incredibly moving and I'd love to
hear more about
um their decision to film that segment
to go home like how was that whole
process for you
for you well Julie is now a Jersey girl
herself too so I think she was just you
know channeling and wanting to yeah it
was in that early interview that you
mentioned Springsteen so then I'm like
okay Springsteen's coming in here and
that means we have to go to Jerusalem
right
um I mean to me I
we could speak about it more
um
I I honestly Bruce Springsteen had a big
impact in mind coming out as intersex
the year that I came out is actually the
youth that I really got into spring
Scene It was 2017 it was the year his
autobiography board to run came out
which like changed my life
um and I think what he speaks so
poetically about growing up in New
Jersey is like you know you're growing
up a bridge and tunnel away from the
greatest city in the world
you have this feeling of like being an
outsider and
you know the outside looking in and
never quite being where you are or who
you are and that's how I always felt
about being
like
I didn't know how to inhabit my body and
I didn't know what kind of body I had so
it it just my love for Bruce and the way
he writes about New Jersey was just
always so intertwined with how I felt
also about being from New Jersey
um and
um
Julie was kind of just picking up what I
was putting down in terms of
that kind of poetic you know
allegory towards you know my body and my
hometown and the additional layer of
um being a first generation Southern
American and this relationship with my
parents of you know not being I'm quite
American but you know
having a connection to my parents and
this other country and having these
these longings to to be more Salvadorian
or to be more American and again it's
this like space in between that
um first generation
um children of immigrants uh wrestle
with which I think is the same middle
ground as being intersex you know
quite either gender you're not really in
the binary benefit of anything really
um which is also like being from New
Jersey which is awesome
like if you go go around you know make
movies out of it but um yeah please do
I am okay tell us more about that
it's called the Ponyboy
[Applause]
[Music]
that's soon yeah
it's a big thing get into it
I love
um I want to know Julie what did you
learn I mean I
even imagine the amount of things but
what is maybe the thing that you you
know hope to carry through your life
most that you learned from the interest
service community and make
it
um you know
I mean a lot of what I learned was some
of the very specific information about
what it is to be intersex
and how the the missteps basically that
the medical community has made towards
dealing with intersex people but I think
in terms of like what that I bring away
it really has a lot more to do with the
spirit of
kind of the
empowering side of coming forward and
fighting for yourself and others kind of
leaving aside what the results of that
all might be you know when you start
filming a verite dock you're thinking
like oh what's going to be the big
what's the big final scene like there's
so many things that the activists are
fighting for right now with you know
there's educate there's awareness
education campaigns there's trying to
change medical practices through mental
institutions and medical schools there's
State legislation there's like all these
fights going on like which of these
things are we gonna follow because like
we want there to be the big third act
Victory and then literally our second
day of filming was that demonstration
and like that's the third act Victory is
like people coming forward and fighting
and like whether whether that changes
the externals or not is important but
isn't the beautiful moment the beautiful
moment is the internal moment to stand
up for one's own self and others and to
fight no matter what and seeing that
happen was moving to me and I hope it's
moving in the film and like my lesson is
like to leave aside outcomes a little
more and think what what it takes
internally to
to fight the fight that River and others
are fighting
[Applause]
yeah I mean I just think in general that
there is so much wisdom and knowledge
and perspective to be gained from the
queer community and
um I I wonder River uh what kind of
things that you hope
um the intersex Community can teach
other people and what we you know gain
from learning more about people in the
full spectrum of the lgbtq eye
experience
yeah when you said that I thought about
like yeah thinking about
the intersex experience in relation to
the queer community and you know I have
to just call it out like most of the
queer Community also still doesn't know
what intersex is
and
did I get a snap there
thank you
um but it's true I think I think there's
this idea of when when one group fights
for something you know they kind of
don't help the person coming after and I
think right now especially with all
these anti-transfills happening they all
have loopholes in it to continue these
surgeries on intersex kids and to deny
gender Reformation for Trans youth but
to continue these gender quote-unquote
normalization or mutilation
surgeries on intersex kids but we talk
about the transportion of it but we're
not talking about the intersex portion
of it at all
and these are across bills and all these
conservative States so
my biggest hope is for the queer
Community
um to start rallying and Galvanize
behind the intersex rights movement and
know that it's a it's
it interests people are now in the
position of
finally speaking out for themselves and
having that courage to do so but we
can't it's not sustainable if we don't
have allies within our own Community
um
let alone you know non-queer people as
well and so but what was your question
um
I don't know I I lost it too I think in
that I was just thinking about I mean I
think it's just such a
wasted opportunity not to when people
you know can when literally the the
embodiment of uh
going away from this binary system that
we know has inherent roots and a lot of
patriarchal
um when we have you know a literal
embodiment of that in these beautiful
people in this film and around us uh I
just think that there's so much that you
know the World At Large that like we
don't know and that we don't talk about
and it's to me it's exciting to to think
about how we can see things with less
binary terms yeah everything I think
something that intersects people really
highlight I always think of it like on
on a more philosophic or existential
maybe even metaphysical level of just we
represent the uncertainty and the
unknown and you know binaries are clean
and easy to understand but the reality
is like all of us live in so many
different spectrums that we can't fully
even comprehend our own existence is
most
of the tent that we do because it's
easier to do that and it's easier to
like live an illusion but the reality is
is that intersection of exist the
reality is instead of like sexualities
on the Spectrum genders on the Spectrum
you know and so I think the more we can
become more intimate with the unknown
um and embrace it the more we could all
like evolve as a species yes
[Applause]
um we will wrap up in just a couple
minutes but I wondered um from both of
you if there was anything that didn't
make it into the film that you are sad
about that you that maybe you could
share with us a little behind two things
I had I had a lunch with my managers who
are here that didn't get in
I've also had a little interview with my
high school principal it was really
sweet and like like she was like my
favorite like Italian teacher
um
and and but like I didn't know she
became principal and then she I like
showed up in the high school and she had
like a you were all welcome here like
rainbow pillow on her like couch which
was crazy because like when I was in
high school we didn't have like
since now have like this like queer
Advocate principle was really sweet but
you'll never see it
special features on a DVD
yeah
it's adorable we edited it perfectly it
was a last minute it was a last minute
economy down tonight
I think that's wise
um was there anything that you
particularly wish people could see that
they missed
you know there's a lot of information
like this was a tricky film in that way
because actually
like it's
it it is educational even if that's like
as a movie you don't want it to feel
educational and but because I I do
understand that people are coming into
this with a very low Baseline of
knowledge there's like so much that you
do number in the film so I guess I you
know there's actually a fair amount of
work that um Cipher is doing to educate
uh medical students about intersex
issues and we filmed some scenes for
those it was interesting it was super
technical and it sort of pulled you away
from like the story Vibe but it was very
good information so really more than
wanting to change the film I want people
to like immediately start googling after
the information about intersex
variations and treatment of intersex
people and intersex human rights is out
there there's organizations like uh
interact intersex Justice project a
support group called interconnect which
all like there is information to be
found and I hope people go and find it
um I don't you
like not I like a movie it's a fail
movie-ish even if you're happy to be
learning some things so
awesome well um where can everybody in
here tell their friends and family to
see the movie yeah so this movie is
opening Nationwide this Friday June 30th
[Applause]
jumped on board
um when you know at the very beginning
to fund this film and to distribute it
so if you go to everybodytickets.com you
can see a lot of the theaters
um that it's at some of the small Indie
theaters don't necessarily populate onto
that site so if you have a theater that
you love the Joe's dots it may you
should check out that theater but um you
know in uh in L.A it's going to be at um
AMC The Grove it's going to be at Lemley
um so please tell your friends
yes that's always good so please
tell people a word about your use your
mouth to say those words use your mouth
um well yeah I want to thank Focus
Features and I want to thank River and
Julie thank you both so much
[Music]